no idea what's happening in this place
it's okay we don't need to know because
we have somebody that plays chess now
better than us grand master abhimanyam
mishra only 12 years old he has won his
game and before we got into that game
let us figure out how he thinks of this
position let's test him out yeah thank
you alejandro yes that's a very it seems
like it's a very strange position with
the king on g5 i mean yeah it's like
very double-edged i'm not sure exactly
what's going on
yeah well your game was uh not
doublished but much more of a
strategical affair take us through that
one yeah so like in the opening he
played this very interesting queen c2
idea so the main point of this queen c2
is that something you can you keep the
flexibility of knight c3 or knight bd2
and then i had this planet of knight bd7
with b6 which should be seven the idea
of this is eventually some c5 and yeah
here knight bd2 is one of the moves but
i think knight c3 is a bit more testing
because the reason is there are some
lines like in this in
in a semi-slab where white goes for this
the same setup with like with the nail
on c3 but he goes for like bishop the
bishop is already on e2 and later he
developed he develops it to d3 so here
if you put the noun on c3 it's
it's it's a better version because yeah
the bishop can go to d3 in one move
but yeah he played the snipe this knight
vd2 setup i took on c4 went c5 and this
is
like a also maybe in some lines with the
knight on c3 whenever you play c5 maybe
d5 yeah
and this is this is a quite fine
position for black and it's fighting
position exactly what i wanted
so he played queen b3 which
queen b3 was a bit interesting but i'm
not exactly sure on what it was doing
because generally in hanging pawn
structure white is trying to attack on
the king side like instead of queen v3 i
think 95 is a bit more accurate
with the idea of like if knight takes e5
details e5 you can win h7
and otherwise there's some
some f4 ideas but i don't think it's
like it's still fine for black but i
think this is more this is a better try
for white
he played queen b3 which i don't think
is really a good move i play i just kept
developing with queen c7 and now the
next few moves it was a bit difficult
for both sides to come up with the plan
i just like i brought my bishop to g7
which prevents d5 like once and for all
well that looks like a very crafty plan
yeah and he played this visual a2 move
which is a bit
i'm not sure like on what he was doing
because d5
it would it still would not work with
the bishop on a2 in fact it kind of
makes it worse because every time you
take on d5 it a2 will also hang it just
felt like in the last few moves you were
going the right direction you were
improving your position while he was
creating more weaknesses for himself
yeah
bishop c6 bishop c3 i played a5 the idea
is because i mean with bishop c3 i guess
white would maybe potentially want to
play a5 against a move like say queen b7
and yeah queen b7 a5 he gets to trade
off this weak a4 pawn and
yeah it's around equal
and instead of like and when i played
bishop c6 the main idea is i want to
play queen b7 and d5 did not work
because of knight c5 first because
after knight c5
it was just winning for black because
you win this d5 pawn
yeah so bishop c3 and now i played a5 to
prevent this a5 push
and here he played rook v1 which
i think he completely missed my next
move which was knight d5 right we were
mentioning this in commentary it's such
a nice strategical accomplishment for
you to break out of the third rank yeah
because uh c65 shifting d5 i just went
upon
and yeah he played bishop a1 knight b4
instead of knight b4 and f4 also looked
quite promising but i thought that since
i played a5 b6 it's a bit of weakness
even though my neon d7 is protecting it
i wanted to let my knight go free and
like some e5 ideas now are possible
right and therefore i put my name on b4
and if i drop bc one because after
knight before i have another which was
saying knight takes it so say he makes a
random move like say king h1
there's knight takes a two queen takes
a2 bishop takes f3
and now knight takes f3 c4 is going to
hang and you could you do not want to
play g6 f3 right
so yeah he played this
after the night before he played rook c1
and now i decided that all of white's
pieces are not looking great as such but
if you give way another move i guess
he'll play bishop one with the idea
playing bishop c3 because bishop sees
the direct leaders knight d3 and once
bishop b1 happens bishop comes to e4 and
yeah
like black's position is still more
preferable but it's not so it's not such
a big advantage definitely but you broke
just yeah i broke the b5
and
knight takes e5 and yeah bishop takes e5
yeah and it seemed like after the
complications especially here after
rookie one white's position was just
fell apart it's not enough activity yeah
and this bish1v1 it's better than on a2
but even here it's just staring to my
pawn on g6 and there are a lot of
variations where i was getting trapped
right and queen d7 was one of the ways
we were looking at for you to cash in
this must have been your choice
and a smooth sailing yeah and i felt
like this queen eight move was a bit
more was a like a very accurate move
just preventing any counter play on b6
like i think queen e6 is also probably
winning
with the ending but i just didn't want
to give him any chance with my isolated
fonts
no this seems absolutely accurate and a
new and nice smooth sailing here you
move to winning two in a row how does it
feel uh to be playing here how's your
performance feel here so far yeah it
feels great to win two two games in a
row like after my start and my i played
a not a great game against ali morandi
and yeah that game was a bit like it was
very difficult for me because i mean he
sacked his two pawns in the opening with
this preparation and i could not react
well and lost
and yeah it feels amazing to win two in
a row in this very strong tournament
manu always a pleasure to have you here
in the studio always a pleasure to see
you doing well and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you christian
absolutely a lot of pressure on this
young man future of chess in america no
not that big of a deal right